should we uh should we move on to the
Chazz yes please this is the moment you
have all your warlord been waiting for
Brad is running the show here for those
that aren't familiar the Chazz is the
capitol hill autonomous zone in Seattle
where a bunch of far-left e-types have
occupied this space rather poorly now
III I've seen a bunch of conflicting
reports some state that in the morning
the barricade just got moved over by
random people and the car started going
driving through again and it was gone
like it was normal yeah it's like back
to normal but then protesters started
showing up and then pulled them back in
I guess I don't know exactly what
happened and then there are some reports
now that I've seen video the cops going
back into their precinct oh they went
back yeah so I don't know if there's if
it has still a thing interest like you
know I gotta say first just the context
it's like they've there's there's John
Brown Gun Club which is a leftist you
know affiliate anti anti fulfill eiated
kind of group and they're armed and
they're allowed to go around armed and
do their thing you know they're guarding
the barricades apparently checking for
weapons trying to make sure no white
supremacists are coming and no cops come
in and stuff like that which is weird
because it means you have no freedom of
movement and no Fourth Amendment rights
really checkpoints yeah police precinct
like right in the center of chess I
think it's not right it kind of the way
it's set up like a t-shape I guess okay
so it's like on one of one of the
streets or whatever but so they're there
and it's funny if like CNN Oliver Darcy
said if you listen to right-wing media
they'll tell you anti famila tents armed
anti-fur militants have seized a portion
of Seattle the mayor says no such
interactions have occurred and the funny
thing about that is what does the
interaction with the mayor have to do
with whether or not protesters are
occupying this section of the city
there's videos of it there's photos of
it CNN is they this is the craziest
thing CNN just lies yeah it's amazing
how obvious and ridiculous the lies are
but people are really dumb and they
don't do research so then they end up
not knowing anyway in this space a
portion of the capitol hill autonomous
zone includes a park with grass well
because it's autonomous that means
they must grow their own food yep
unfortunately in the past they were
asking so I actually heard that that
vegan meat tweet wasn't real oh it
wasn't I couldn't find it I couldn't I
can't find it they may have deleted it
no that that person they made their
Twitter private but you should still be
able to find search for the terms and
find cash diversions on Google and I
couldn't do it okay so I kind of am
leaning towards it's probably not a real
tweet but everybody took it and just
assumed it was real still but who knows
it's funny either way either way I gotta
give it to there's a couple things you
will need if you want an autonomous zone
and one of those things is
self-sufficiency yes well I bring I
bring you now to that she has updates
yes this person I love these photos they
have a farm up as of today most of them
have probably never seen a cow in real
life let alone do any gardening so a lot
of the plants aren't even planted and
half of them are staring at it half of
them are staring at it expecting to grow
into ripe tomatoes any minute now I
bring you the first photo I am so sorry
what is what's wrong with these people
this this I'm not a farmer and I still
understand the concept of digging holes
and placing plants in them Wow yeah and
growing things like we have a garden way
better than that okay where it
definitely takes at least three months
to two days and months to grow food they
literally dumped topsoil on top of the
grass under it looks like hardboard yeah
it looks like they dumped the dirt on
top of the grass but on top of newspaper
now I will admit there's there's almost
paper everywhere it does look like they
just dumped topsoil on grass no no no
they put newspaper down first and then
dump the look at that
that's newspapers newspaper all over the
place yeah I know but I doesn't mean in
the entire thing I guess I see it all
the way across over here like yeah
there's newspaper poking through the
dirt oh yeah they're doing I take a look
at this one don't know I love this is my
favorite they've literally just dropped
potted plants on top of the soil that's
it
Oh looks like they're prepping though
like looks like they're prepping to put
them in okay okay maybe they've once
seen a nature show or something
they might actually this okay maybe
unfair to criticize them because maybe
they're just getting started but I'm not
entirely convinced well if only you knew
how bad things really are and there's a
frump Tovar plant dropping a pot on top
of the dirt it does look like a sad plan
what's the last one I mean that's how
they come now now to the store had
gotten plants like that that's how they
come now hold on to - I think a lot of
people are trying to make it seem like
this guy's got his hands on his head
like he's like oh jeez like what do we
do tying his hair back exactly I do
these guys these guys are tying their
hair that could be a mask right it
doesn't change the fact that this is
like there's nothing wrong with a man
bun okay I know it's for the record just
saying you know what this is this is
like what the system you ever uh you
know you know you make cookies yeah and
you like roll out you put a rolling pin
down and your cookie cutter mm-hmm and
you press the cookie cutter and you do
it as evenly as possible to maximize the
amount of cookie dough it gets cut sure
and then you have those just just trashy
edges and you're like well I got this
big wad of dough it's all just the the
leftover edges and it can't really do it
is food you can't like do anything with
it okay that's what this is in society
this is the outer edge of the cookie
dough not the cookies themselves it's
the part where you're like I can see
that it's dough but I can't do anything
with it so you have people who have like
a cursory understanding of like the
plant goes in the dirt and then you put
water on it and food comes out yep yeah
that's a general thing you can
understand it but they have no expertise
no specialties than any of this stuff
they got that part though yeah
apparently someone was even saying that
the John Brown Gun Club are extremely
inept when it comes to guns oh really I
don't know if that's true dangerous
cuz I'm like I'm not gonna print like I
know better than they do okay but you
know someone was actually saying in the
superjet the other day they were like
these people have no idea what they're
doing their training is awful yeah I
would not be surprised you see all these
people and they come down and I bring
you now
to one of my favorite wait wait go back
go back real quick do you think there's
a soy beans in there oh of course the
other thing the other thing I'd be
waiting to ask come on what are they
growing and have they considered at all
the season the temperature
dude when you buy seeds do you ever buy
seeds before yeah and you look on the
back and it's like here's your seasonal
window for your region yep literally
won't send you certain seeds unless it's
the right season yeah
now again I'm making assumptions here
but I think it's fair to make the
assumptions that they have just taken
random potted plants and poured topsoil
in the dirt and place them on top of it
they're probably too close together to
muss and love this most never never seen
a cow in real life yeah it's funny if
someone was like man we should send them
some some cows and chickens and I'm like
do you think any of those people would
know how to like dude that cow would
mess them up
probably yeah you know how to turn that
chicken into food probably not so
apparently someone said they're gonna
bring a cow down really yeah and they
got all excited enough was a troll or
not yeah someone was like I've secured a
cow and they gave all the details and
like we're gonna bring it down yeah and
then what are you gonna do with it what
are you going to do with the cow right
are you gonna have it just graze it's
okay is the cow pregnant does it ever
did it have a calf is it gonna produce
milk or is it literally just a cow yeah
they have no idea how any of this works
it's like the story I was telling you
about the people from Occupy got a farm
you know and they quit for two weeks
like that was too hard that's way too
hard no thanks this is LARPing they're
there they're bored and they're playing
their version of like well what should
we do next guys let's make a garden how
about we give up bags of sprite I've
never seen a second sprite before but it
is very sad I respect this 100% I
respect their making they're making do
with what they have there creating
plastic waste okay sure what are they
gonna do this is gonna drink the spray
throw it on the ground
sprite it's hilarious okay now listen if
I had a big listen hold on hold on if I
had to figure out how to distribute from
a 2 liter and I had no cups and I had
ziplock bags I'd put him in the bag I do
yeah but even okay even as much as I
will
fact what they're doing you have to
understand how hilarious it is that
they've literally got in a little bowl
full of baggies full of sprite and
they're asking you to take one of them
yes I agree it's very funny this looks
like utopia to me I don't know what you
guys are looking at this tweet is a Phil
Phil that remains from all that remains
said I am relieved the Chazz has
necessities like sprite in a bag it
really it really really is funny it is
so they've they've figured it out now
and I'm sprite of all so does yeah like
what you know I'm in like alright I
don't mind sprite I guess I am as a
should drink just drink water water yeah
well good but the best for you if you're
gonna be living off the land in my
opinion I think I am I am I am deeply
offended by what these people are doing
oh yeah no not really it's just like I'm
kidding but there's they're such obvious
like they're so obviously it's like the
the cookie analogy I was giving right
mm-hmm
so in society you have this cookie dough
and then you have the carpenter that's a
cookie the fireman that's a cookie and
then you have the outer edges that are
somewhat useless and nothing to do with
and so they go here and they just this
analogy is perfect yeah they're just
what are they doing and why are they
doing it they don't it's not autonomous
they're literally bringing in sprite
manufacturer to the plant that produces
plastic probably in Mexico or something
bringing it up there and then going like
we're autonomous and they're pointing
sprite in baggies you know what man look
I once was talking to a friend it was an
activist and thought they were changing
the world and I said no you're only
fighting for your community and they
were like no I'm fighting for everyone
I'm like you're using a Samsung computer
man you know what the Foxconn
laboratories people walking off the
building right you're not fighting for
the world you're fighting for yourself
these people are peak capitalism totally
this is this is like you know in The
Hunger Games capital city where they
were drinking epic act to vomit so they
can eat more
you know this is the absolute excess of
society that has nothing functional to
do so they're bored out of their minds
so they show up the Seattle barrack hit
it off give out bags of sprite and they
have no idea what farming is other than
farming exists wait how come these
plants aren't growing maybe we should
give them a little
I got a drag I got a drag pack Alinsky
yes do it
now Kyle's a good dude III think he's I
think he's a good honest guy I disagree
with him on probably I don't really
watch his stuff but calculon's Kay's a
progressive commentator who was flying
in a plane and looked at the window and
saw farms took a picture and then
tweeted something like it's so beautiful
I wonder why it looks this way and
people responded with like I are you are
you kidding like you joking farts like
you took a picture of farms and he was
like well I didn't know it's like you
didn't know to fart now not to be fair I
think it's okay not everybody should
know what a farm is okay but I am kind
of shocked that you can be I don't how
old the guy is in his 30s and not
understand that he was looking at farms
when I was the first time I flew I think
I was like 16 or 17 okay and I looked
down I went whoa so that's what farms
look like like what else do you think
they are I was I was like eight
when I first flew and I think the same
thing yeah now hold on okay hmm now with
all due respect to Kyle I'm not trying
to be a dick or anything yeah
but take a look at you you can consider
how he'll look at these farms and
doesn't understand their farms what do
you think someone of his political
persuasion would do when they're told
you need to be autonomous they don't
know what farms look like so I mean you
you go back to what they're doing first
of all it's it's like where's a circular
plot of land where they just dump
topsoil on top of the grass on top of
newspapers I'm sorry I'm not letting
that go does look like his newspaper
underneath the dirt now now hold on hold
on I got venting the roots from even
going through the grass to fight through
right the grass for nutrients I gotta
stop and say is there something I don't
know about farming cuz I'm not a farmer
but I I am not familiar with the
newspaper technique it's possible that
they think this is part of composting
like they expect the paper to break down
like they don't realize how long it
takes maybe it will rain and something
yeah exactly that would work in a
compost pit but put nutrients back into
soil to use that soil again but I got it
but my other question is like what is
this and why did people just show up and
just place potted plants on top of the
dirt that I bet just to me looks like
there this is where all the plants are
gonna go they to get started definitely
let's check
tomorrow that's what that looks yeah
this this photo might be before the
other one well there's no this one is
where they actually saw another picture
where there's two circles oh really it's
for that look you can even see and go
back you can see in this picture that
with nothing planted so what are they
hold on man do they know how long it
takes to grow this stuff that's what I
was saying earlier it's like so you guys
are all prepped and ready to eat in
three and a half months nice job guys
well that's why I think it's funny that
Chaz update said there's half a more
staring at it expecting it to grow into
ripe tomatoes and oh man well I got to
pull up whatever this tweet is what is
this one Chaz now Chaz after two weeks
and there's tractors pulling and then it
says chanson for two months and there's
Raz the warlord looking at all the fine
crops of wheat is that is that Kim Jong
on I think so well good for them I'm
having fun yeah I you know what I find
that she has endearing now I can now not
to be fair we're all laughing at it
right yeah yeah you won't be laughing in
six months when they have like this
massive field of crops and there's like
three hundred armed dudes well-trained
wearing like you know full SWAT gear and
they're guarding it and the military
can't get in who's doing the work though
no one's producing anything they do
don't want to work for it
let me tell you exactly how these things
goes that go down cuz I've seen that Oh
tell me Tim they all show up and they're
like this is an autonomous zone and
they're like rad what do we do well we
need food how do we get it bro and then
he pulls out a bucket and goes we do the
drum circles no he doesn't even suggest
you started doing it and they're all
Stan they're all like funny thing about
Occupy Wall Street was the evolution of
the of the instruments through time yeah
yeah it was like when Occupy first
started someone was banging on a bucket
then someone else brought like a wind
instrument and then brass instrument and
then stringed instruments and then
slowly evolved into like full ban with
guitars and like people singing and I
was like wow in two weeks they've gone
from the the you know the primitive
prehistoric you know like yeah caveman
music of banging all the way into the
advanced
you know compositional structure of
modern times it's inspiring to see next
I'll have a full orchestra oh here we go
check it out you were right you were no
way all right boys we got a new photo
that she has community garden they
actually planted the sprouts but it's in
a very unorganized fashion obviously
none of these people have farmed before
but hey what can you expect it's Seattle
you you were right it's it's it's
cardboard we hold that's even worse you
go through I'm so confused
I got a stop Oh I'm assuming there must
be something I don't know about why you
put cardboard down before planting some
and not only that look you were right
they are putting it straight on top of
the grass so yeah I know so the grass
roots are all underneath the cardboard
this would be able to go down in I went
around and expand to gather new someone
someone says see see here this is the
point I was making because I'm not a
farmer someone said it's permaculture it
should work but they're still doing it
horribly wrong okay so they had the idea
all right so this is respected this is
exactly kind of what I was saying though
that like they saw something on TV and
they were like put cardboard down and
then dump the dirt on top of it now but
but I wanted to be careful about how
we're going through this because I don't
know about farming man I bet they got
all of their farming tips from 4chan
that's entirely possible
no not roll that out and someone in for
chance like oh I got him good oh yeah
well it kind of makes sense because I
found like layers of burlap or whatever
as I'm googling it something like there
has to be some reason they're doing this
they don't look totally off the chain
they just look like they had a seedling
of an idea and they didn't really know
how to fall through well I've served on
a farm before and I've never seen that
yeah culture Bowe and that's and that's
why it also has a huge farm like 200
acres and then I've worked with
permaculture people up in New York
you've never seen him lay cardboard cup
of grass and then dump soil on it that's
what causes me to giggle yeah that's
what it is no I've never seen that no
it's ridiculous so someone someone on
the super chat says how are they going
to weed their farm how are they going to
make sure the plants get water even
jesus H Christ no just know nothing of
what the chance is doing makes sense
coming from someone who grows plants
oh no super Jenna yeah I'm just looking
at what people are saying because I'm
like listen man listen
imagine how stupid we would look if
we're sitting here like Tweedledee and
Tweedledum laughing how dumb they are
and that's actually a real technique cuz
I don't know I don't form so technically
I've been around farmers yeah Adam knows
but I I'm reading this just now this
might be relatively new which might be
why you haven't seen anything like this
but they're talking about how cardboard
is a good way to keep grass and weeds
from growing through so maybe they are
yeah and that were behind that's for
like front lawns with flowers and stuff
weeds from going through this is your
scale for sure but you can't just put
like a four-inch layer of dirt on top of
that plants need to grow in like they
need root I don't know man sums are
important what okay so so we have some
misinformation updates we got to go
through here
she has update says the document this
person who tweeted documenting
misinformation she has is out of food
supplies have been stolen by homeless
warlords run in the community people
have given up and it's shut down food is
plentiful plentiful the atmosphere is
friendly still holding up pictures below
taken same day as post so here's what
someone I saw this post and then I
believe it was real they said the
Seattle Capitol Hill autonomous zone
LARP is over the kids couldn't go for
one day without food so they left true
radical purveyors of a revolutionary
change no doubt the next photo we see no
it's still all there and this flies in
the face of CNN we're trying to claim it
like none of this is going on
here's people like playing music hanging
out and and there you go so Chaz update
says this is correct Chaz still does
have food they've ordered pizzas and
everything they're not out of food or
anything and most likely won't be for a
while it's still holding up quite well
despite the idiots I don't know who Chaz
updates is but they're having a good
time making that making fun of everybody
definitely and I appreciate it here we
go the cow will not produce milk until
her demands are met concerns barricade
safety trash medical deliveries first
responder access guns check and a may
for the cow well I wish that she has oh
here we
what's this Seattle PD and chief Carmon
best have entered the East precinct to
inspect the building officers have made
it clear they wanted the building back
whoa what's gonna happen bags of sprite
will be given out and will the blue all
right I don't know what else there what
else is going on but well uh well we'll
keep an eye out for what's happening
over in the Chazz and the Chazz having
fun what is this update account for the
wacky s that is happening at Capitol
Hill autonomous zone Chazz and this
guy's firing laser beams from his eyes
yeah so they're gonna form ridiculous
they're gonna become autonomous though
they still require the Domino's to bring
their food how many people are there do
you know like according to their village
according to the Wikipedia for the
independent government of chas 200 200
but they do have 500 I believe there are
500 residences within the area they
control Wow all right so that those
little circles not enough food that's
enough food for maybe two people half a
person well sure
for like I mean it looks like cuz you
got a harvest it and we'll wait for it
to become harvestable yeah they're
LARPing then harvest it it's a game
they're playing cop that everyone gets a
slice of tomato they're playing a game
of rebels at what they think they're
playing they're playing rebels and
revolutionaries in their backyard yeah
and they're pretending the farm they saw
something on the internet they laid out
cardboard dumped soil on top of it and
on it and then they placed potted plants
on top of the soil all right I guess
some people are saying it's bad some
people are saying that the general the
general idea is there cardboard is to
stop the grass to get dirty yeah maybe
they're doing it because they expect to
move it all after the fact I want the
grass to stay there you know no the
grass will get killed
yeah but how long probably I mean after
a few weeks if all right so they're
gonna be there for a day and they know
it so they're there to play wrote you
know rebels and revolutionaries with
their friends and they and they don't
want to hurt the park so they've laid
the stuff out so they can move it later
that's very nice they're playing a game
and they're gonna and they're and
they're ordering pizzas basically like
you know like where's on the other day
like mom can we get pizza with like
extra pepperoni
no don't get pepperoni because people
are vegan oh can we get it with with the
peppers and
the mushrooms but but don't do cheese
because Billy's vegan and then she's
like okay okay I'll go get your pizza
for you I mean really think about what
it is they come and play music they talk
they do like you know hippy dancing and
stuff people are planting you know
potted plants that like I wish never
could have seen the look at your face
look they won't have a farm with food
right yeah they would need to tell like
there's a little feel yeah they still
wouldn't you're yeah everyone in their
community
you're so funny the funny thing about it
is none of these people understand at
all how much labor goes into producing
enough food for one person yeah exactly
and that's why the when they fly over
these fields and they can see just like
as far as the eye can see farm so like I
wonder what those things are
yeah cuz they assume like you plant one
thing in the garden then you have food
for a year yeah yeah it's like let's
just put 50 plants in the dirt and we'll
feed 200 people no they clearly don't
want to feed people they're not trying
to feed people know they're just LARPing
it is the edges of the cookie dough you
can't use right there's have to work
that's how it is when you take a cookie
cutter and you cut out that nice perfect
circle that full circle is one job
outside of it is just tidbits they can't
do anything I mean it's there you don't
the dough I guess yeah you do they can't
do anything for anybody so they go and
play make-believe cuz they're bored yep
yep well I wish I wish she has the best
and I have to say yeah I find it all I
find it all very endearing and kind of
cute it's like a bunch of little kids
playing a game of cops and robbers yeah
and we're laughing at having a good time
at the absurdity of what it is they
think they're doing but but it's the
people who think their actual
revolutionaries walking around with guns
and they're like yeah and then you're
just like in that cute I'll tell you
what man someone's telling me to look up
operation homeless on 4chan have you
seen have you seen the photos of the
John Brown Gun Club guys no what no what
we've we've seen on our show like
yesterday you posted you sure right so
thanks they're there they're standing at
the barricades and they've got rifles
you go what are you gonna do I don't
know what's been it was good you proud
boy shows up and walks in when
you shoot him cop shows up he's got a
gun he says move we're gonna do you're
gonna move yep
it's completely useless they're just
LARPing they're having their moment
where they get to pretend to be Fidel
Castro or you know whatever staging the
revolution of the streets people are
gonna come in and it's gonna be a bunch
of ineffective hippie dancing and their
demands make literally no sense one of
their demands is black doctors for black
people yeah why why yeah they one of the
demands is in the health care system if
a black person goes to the hospital
there's a black doctor who will treat
them do they want to be like segregated
is that what the yes they do yes now I
don't know if all of them do but but
during Ferguson I believe it was
Ferguson there was a letter written that
said that to the activists segregation
was a plot by white supremacists to
force them to be second-class citizens
I'm not exaggerate this is literally
what they argued that some activists
okay it the argument was during
segregation they built up their own wall
street they you know in in Tulsa I guess
it was called and it was fire bombed and
destroyed by white supremacists or
something like that okay they actually
had their own parallel economy growing
building their own homes and families
and everything okay it got destroyed
segregation ends and they argue that
that was the plan by the the white
supremacists so that these people would
be kept in perpetual poverty and never
rise above white people that's what some
of the black lives matter activists
believe I'm not gonna pretend like it's
everybody but that was one of the things
that was being circulated when I was
down there but I mean think about where
we've gone since then to entertain that
argument under the Democrats things
haven't been going well for the black
community and I'm not gonna pretend and
play this game works like they're the
real racists no no no you can believe
whatever you want to believe it the
demek about the democrats but come on
let's take a look at these cities these
cities in these states that are
overwhelmingly blue that have all of the
problems they complain about that's not
I don't mean the end of the bike
community
I mean there's an social justice
activists which includes you know black
lives matter and and you know just
general social justice critical race
Theory all of these lefties are like
police brutality is a huge problem right
in cities loose blue cities in big
cities right agreed agreed
yeah okay sure not in small town bumpkin
Ville where
where officer friendly knows your dad
you know it's in the big cities and you
can argue that maybe that has to do with
like we've argued about community
policing like the cops don't know
anybody yeah but that doesn't explain
other places like we talked about this
to Tokyo where they have bigger cities
and they don't have the same problems so
perhaps that argument they made about
segregation isn't necessarily wrong and
that Michael Bloomberg for instance who
ran as a Democrat recently is overtly
racist and even said so proudly on a
recording where he's like yep I do this
specifically because you know and
targeting them might based on their race
yeah so listen man I'm not gonna pretend
to know all throughout history whatever
all the conspiracies the plans were but
there's certainly some people who feel
that the Democrats plan the whole time
was to keep them subjugated through
these horrible horrible policies and put
them in cities and then have police go
around beating the crap out of people I
don't say it's true I'm just saying
that's one of the reasons they probably
believe that's the case I certainly
think segregation is a horrible horrible
thing and I you know I like the idea of
us all being Americans me too and just
hanging out with people one hang out
with and being buddies with people of
all different races and that's what it
was like for me grip on the south side
of Chicago hear hear yeah well now
you're actually hearing for people who
want segregation like they want
graduation ceremonies for only one race
you know things like that I don't yeah
it gets going backwards exactly it's
it's it's identitarian isn't men it's
you know there was there was a really
funny thing I think I think it was
Sargon who said this so I got of a cod
okay Carl Benjamin he was like the sjw's
in the alt-right want the exact same
things why don't they work together yeah
that's interesting point yeah it's like
they make they disagree on what should
be on top of things but they agree on
the separation or whatever then let him
do it like that
congratulations you know go do your
thing we got to judge people on their
character right exactly all those skin
is irrelevant
yeah yep and and sure there's problems
with our society but let's fix the
society let's let's tweak what needs to
be tweaked we're a country of reform but
let's stay together right otherwise
we're gonna be fighting each other yeah
I think that's gonna happen I think it's
inevitable right each other in some form
or another you know the way I see it is
the dominoes have already fallen over
you know and the avalanche has already
started there's no way to stop it at
this point it's it's it's it's going
down the hill and I look at generals
coming out in opposing Trump and I see
them hedging their bets they're
literally in the Matt Taibbi wrote this
last October that we were in the
counting heads phase who's loyal to who
and so now the generals are saying not
to Trump they're gonna call them out
that way if something happens and Trump
gets disavowed or something like that or
you know they don't to be seen as Trump
loyalists yeah so then they're like oh
no we-we-we spoken against them I think
when you have all of this media I think
this is what a lot what the Democrats
may be hoping for to scare people into
thinking no one supports them and
they're on the wrong side of history
so they panic and just capitulate yeah
but I wonder if because of the secret
ballot it won't be enough but maybe
that's why they want mail-in voting this
is the funniest thing man I'll tell you
a lot of these high-level journalists I
believe are our authoritarian evil
people it's shocking to me when in New
Jersey you have this crazy story where a
head of the N double ACP says cancel the
entire election because mail-in voting
failed and 20% of the vote was
disqualified and then you look at
Washington Post New York Times and
there's no evidence of voter fraud
anywhere ever for any reason no but not
real happens and I'm yal sees out there
going we need mail and voting because of
Kovac because of blah blah blah it's
like I stopped listening as soon as I
heard we need mail and vote on it's like
no we don't if you want to talk about it
sure wait till after a huge election
it's not messing with it it's the whole
point they didn't a hundred thousand
vote like mail-in votes just get found
something got misplaced where was that
they got but they got like mis-sent or
mislabeled right you'll never received
out it was like aka they didn't count
they didn't count those votes yeah
exactly and you want to do this yeah I
think if we want to do mail-in voting we
have to have a very secure system
developed over a long period of time
derided tried out yeah and after the
election not before aren't they just
trying to defund the USPS the United
States well that was those Republicans
oh the Republicans won
Democrats were trying to bolster it okay
and the argument the Democrats was that
if they do if the Republicans defund
puzzle the puzzle service we can't have
mail and voting no of course that's why
they want to keep it look I'll tell you
this man I don't trust Republicans on
trusted Democrats I think both sides are
trying to bend the rules to benefit them
to make sure they win because under
Bazin agree they think they're they're
the right ones to win that's always the
problem with that being said I think the
Democrats are completely insane just
100% totally insane you know you look at
CNN right and this is a contributing
factor to why I feel this way Oliver
Darcy says that you know if you watch
right-wing media armed antifoam
militants have taken have seized a
portion of Seattle I mean it's kind of
an extreme way to put it but it's not
necessarily untrue I mean right John
Brown gun club is there running a
checkpoint for an area they deemed
autonomous and we know it exists no he
then says the mayor says they have no
interactions with these people as if
that disqualifies the first point he
made it doesn't just because the mayor
never talked to any these people doesn't
mean it's not happening so when I look
at how CNN is lying all day every single
day I don't trust anything they put out
then I see what the Democrats are doing
and I'm like they're insane people who
just want power but there are people who
think they're the good guys and they
hate Trump I'll tell you what CNN's
lying you there along 100% it's crazy
that I can literally tell you make sure
you watch CNN to know what they're
saying if you don't just watch me watch
CNN watch Fox watch you know
conservatives and progressives and
absorb as much information as possible
you know and then they tell me that I'm
lying to people in training they'll
compare and contrast yeah CNN CNN
literally says don't watch the spin just
come to us for the facts Wow
so this is what I tell people the
easiest way to know whether or not you
are in a cult is if you are forbidden
from learning period
boom any legitimate free-thinking
organization who's on the right side
will tell you learn everything you can
absolutely so my research do the
research I'm talking to this person I
know and I'm like they're like I only
watch you know NPR and this news and I'm
like yeah you're in a cult no I'm not I
know the truth you just believe crazy
things and I said to them the best way
to know if you're in a cult is if you
refuse to learn you know if you say I
know I don't need to learn
congratulations you're in a cult I don't
need to read what you're saying to me or
what that article says because what I
leave is true Yeah right this person
told me sounds pretty religious so
that's that's the best I can say you
know how do you know you're on the right
side you're open to all sides of
information and you're trying your best
to understand how people feel yeah and
when you do that it yeah yeah but also
just you want to know the truth yeah you
can't assume you know you like so you
know what's a saying about you know
stupid people are confident smart people
are so full of doubt yep
that's really what it is so when I read
something I'm like is this true yeah and
so I'll check different sources now
you're looking for New York Times and
they're claiming that it's it's funny
the New York Times claims all this is
happening they're calling it free speech
and free movement and it's a liberated
space CNN's telling you it's literally
not happening at all interesting so like
which is true is it great or is it not
do I do I ignore the photos of people
doing there's videos of this yeah
there's I'm streaming they're walking
around the hole put in the climb song
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you